hopefully you all are able to hear me
I'm currently traveling and uh sitting
in a hotel lobby which is the most fun
place to do virtual presentations as you
have tons of people walking by luckily I
found a spot there's a set of stairs
behind here so you might see random
strangers pass by which you can always
wave to as they go up and down the
stairs as we've passed but good morning
I think for many of you uh good evening
to maybe some of you on the further side
of things including Bianca as well but
I'm excited to chat with you all around
this session around presentation skills
which I think will be a lot of fun if
you have
not joined us before this is our monthly
virtual happy hour so we use that as an
excuse to uncover a couple of
interesting topics get together bring a
little bit of hopefully joy and levity
to the the face as you either start your
day or end your day or middle of the day
depending on where you're joining us
from and each week we have a theme or
each month we have a theme something to
focus on so in the past we've talked
about things like AI in the creative
process using AI we've talked about how
to end your day so that you can relieve
some stress and be more present for your
family or have more energy for your
hobbies
and today we're going to be talking
about
capturing and captivating attention
capturing people's Focus to get things
somewhat maybe casually started I'd love
for you to drop into the chat just
something that you need to communicate
something that you want to that you have
you feel like you need to get out there
and share with the world maybe it is a
topic that you present on oftentimes
maybe it's a presentation that you have
coming up in the future but what's
something that you need to Captivate
people's attention for what message do
you want to share with them drop that in
the chat or you might say just in
general this is a skill set that I want
to to work on but drop in the chat why
you want to be able to Captivate people
there we'll give you a second to think
about that you might also just say duh I
think you need to for any type of
mutation so drop in the chat though why
you want to Captivate people I'll tell
you that my goal in captivating people
is being able to help share this message
of humor to bring a little bit more
levity positivity joy to their day so
yeah Tanya says just general
presentations in life good reason to
like learn this as a valuable skill
Technical Training what a wonderful way
to phrase that Mary of building out the
internet for all maybe somewhat related
to what Bianca shared as Humane
marketing I see we've got some people
wanting to bring the human element to
the things that we do Janine oh I teach
human writing that's amazing fantastic I
hope that you can share some techniques
and tips with me always looking to work
and improve and that's going to be one
of the themes today I think if you want
the most important takeaway right at the
very beginning I guess you could skip
the entire rest of the thing but the
most important thing is going to be
about iteration it's going to be about
this idea that you constantly want to
evolve and tweak and change your message
that's the best way we get better at any
scale but particularly presentation says
are you constantly working to make
things a little bit better
uh next week I will be actually this
weekend I'll be attending the National
Speakers Association in Orlando Florida
so organization dedicated to people like
myself who use speaking as their primary
profession or part of their profession
or they want to and uh one of the
techniques that I learned there from a
fantastic uh comedian she's incredible
humorous named Janine uh Robertson or
Jeannie Robertson and she always said
the biggest takeaway is any presentation
that you do
try to make it five percent better than
the last one that you just did whether
that is a new topic or maybe it's the
same topic it's something how you
constantly it already how are you
constantly tweaking how are you
constantly making improvements so that
at the beginning of the year to the end
of the year you've made massive massive
kind of strides and Improvement in terms
of your presentation style or your skill
set Etc so five percent better I think
is a wonderful skill set to practice and
so that's why Janine I'm hoping you can
share with me some wonderful writing
techniques for human writing for that
iterative process so we're gonna go
ahead and jump in I see that if you take
a look at Sabrina in terms of the video
on the screen we have an almost
two-year-old joining us today looking to
learn a little bit about that but that
is my daughter uh they are in the hotel
room upstairs so my wife and daughter
are joining but I'm guessing my daughter
was like where did Papa go and so now
she's this is where she is so tip number
two two so we talked about iterate
iterate iterate second tip to Captivate
attention is to bring your adorable
children into a zoom meeting with you
for just a brief moment so people are
like who is that child and why are they
here
um so that's tip number two uh so now
we'll jump into some more uh actual uh
techniques because I'll tell you where
some of this comes from from me and I've
shared this story before so you've maybe
heard it maybe many of you may know that
I started my career at Procter Gamble as
an I.T project manager and my background
is in computer science and engineering
so I'm obsessed with efficiency and I
remember on the job at PNG I was
constantly looking at how do I do things
as efficiently as possible to the point
that I created like a startup routine I
don't know if you remember this when
computers used to have a super long
startup time now it takes three or five
minutes but like when I first started at
PNG it would take 15 minutes for your
computer to be and so I had a 15 minute
get ready in the world
do as many activities as I could in
those 15 minutes in terms of clearing
out voicemail and setting up my computer
and setting things up on the side Etc
obsessed with efficiency so I brought
that into all of the work that I did at
PNG and it worked for the most part and
then I remember finding myself
in this meeting that was how should we
say this it was just incredibly boring
it was one of those meetings where you
like won a multi-task and everything
that you do like I was so bored in this
meeting I was like thinking like can I
do some of these other things and I was
brainstorming about the things I wish I
could be doing instead of being in that
boring meeting it was one of those
meetings so dry it makes you want to cry
and so I was daydreaming about things
not even necessarily exciting things but
I was like you know what I'd rather be
folding laundry right now that's how
exciting this means you know what I
maybe I should schedule a root canal
just so I feel something again there's
one of those terribly dry boring
meetings and looking around the room I
could tell I wasn't the only one feeling
that thing right because one person was
just like staring at the clock I don't
know if you've ever done that where
you're in a meeting where you just stare
at the clock and you're like okay I'm
gonna look away from the clock and I'm
not going to look back for five or ten
more minutes right I'm gonna wait until
at least 10 minutes have passed before I
check the time again and you're like
okay it's been at least 10 minutes you
look at 13 seconds all right it's only
been 13 so that's how boring of a
meeting was one one woman in the meeting
had just written the word blah on the
meeting and on her notepad blah and then
she was just circling it like over
and over and the biggest problem with
this particular meeting was that I was
the one
leading the meeting
right and I had this realization where
if I'm bored while talking the audience
has to be bored while listening and
what's interesting about this meeting is
that it was an important meeting it was
a status update on a project that was
behind schedule like it was important
information that I needed to share but
one of the things that I've learned both
in terms of my time at PNG and certainly
with the number of countless of people
that I've worked with since then is that
just because something is important
doesn't mean it's inherently interesting
and so we have to change the way that we
present our ideas because it's not
enough for us to have a good idea it's
not enough for us to be like have a
really important message that people
need to hear it's not enough for us to
say okay we have an idea we're spreading
maybe you've seen tedx talks where
they've had like really interesting
ideas but their presentation skills
aren't very good so you check out after
three or four minutes right we need to
say okay it's not just about the message
but it's also how we share or present
that message and that's what we're going
to talk talk about today is how to
better Captivate your audience how to
help bring a little bit more levity a
little bit more interest into your work
not just so that people think that
you're funny you're engaging or
interesting but more importantly so that
you present you your message more
effectively now I'm curious
you're a smart group I imagine what do
you what goes into an effective
presentation go ahead and drop in the
chat what comes to mind when you think
of an effective presentation or when you
think of someone who is able to
Captivate your audience what techniques
or tips are typically being used share
any thoughts that you have in the
comments in terms of what makes for an
effective or captivating presentation
yeah there's connection with the
audience interest right you find a way
to say okay how do I relate this in
terms of what they understand or what
they enjoy we can say yeah there's
something at the beginning a scroll
stopper so that's a that's a that's good
social media language from Bianca
clearly someone like comes from that
world of scroll stopping in the sense of
what's going to get someone if someone
were to watch this as a video on
Instagram reels what's going to prevent
them from flicking upwards again in just
a moment audience interaction of course
yeah prompting maybe for the check it's
in there building a little bit of
suspense being clear and concise a
memorable story all of these are
fantastic components into a presentation
that go far beyond just the content just
the message just the idea and
we're going to build off of that explore
that as an idea attractive visuals
awesome I love that as well with a quick
exercise and this is also another
exercise we've done in some of our
presentations before but I think it's a
really helpful one to set the stage for
what we're going to talk about but I do
need a volunteer for this exercise is
there anyone willing to come off of mute
and work with me this exercise the only
caveat the only thing that you need to
know in order to do this exercise is to
know what a microwave oven is
right do you know what a microwave is
okay Mary you know in a microwave oven
is fantastic you can help me exercise so
Mary what I want you to do is I want you
to explain to me what a microwave oven
is
uh the caveat is going to be that I am a
cave person okay imagine that I was just
magically transported from the caveman
cave person days and we're standing in
your kitchen we've gone past the things
of hey look we're indoors and indoor
plumbing we've gotten past that but
we're now standing in your kitchen
assuming you have a microwave or
pretending that you have a microwave and
I'm like what is this okay so I want you
to share with me what a microwave oven
is assuming I'm a cave person
hot Firebox
oh Firebox ah fire I know what is box oh
box
magic could
magic I know magic fast
fire Fast Fire fast fire and in in what
is box
small
Square you know a small area a small
area Okay okay
so Fire fast fire in cave
microwave fast and why use microwave
food tastes better
ah food does taste better when hot yeah
and less sick less sick if food is hot
yeah okay excellent uh let's give a
round of applause to Mary nice very
nicely done
um
yeah this is a super fun exercise it's
called explain like I'm blank you can do
this with a lot of different people a
lot of different contexts you can change
you can say microwave cave person or
cell phone to someone from Shakespeare's
time uh it's a great exercise to
practice your communication skills
because you can say explain what you do
for a living to a five-year-old or to my
two-year-old when they join your Zoom
Call Etc so
um there are some applications to it but
uh I'm curious Mary what was your
strategy for trying to explain this
microwave oven to me as a cave person
but it helped that you put fire up there
as a little prompt yeah because it takes
my brain about 15 minutes to boot up in
the morning and it hasn't been that yet
strategy yeah trying to think about what
caveman knows versus not yet magic I
guess that would be
in box I don't know where that came from
yeah in a very explaining a microwave
oven as a magic box it's actually pretty
accurate in some ways I conceptually
know how microwaves kind of work but I
don't know exactly how it works it feels
like magic in many ways and yet I
decided to make it a little bit harder
for you because I knew you could take it
to say okay what is Magic or what is box
and depending on how you do this
exercise some people might say I would
know what a box is I don't know but the
key is that you adjust it that you tweak
the conversation you didn't start
immediately to say oh microwave oven has
a bunch of these buttons on it and it
has electricity and it causes these
microwave art particles in the air to go
and the molecules in the food then go
back and forth and the friction is
actually what heats it up from the
inside it's like you didn't go through
any of that you start it more simply in
in essence when we think about effective
communication it is two things and the
first thing is that effective
communication is first of all it's
relevant to the person that you're
communicating with not necessarily
relevant to you as a communicator why
are you communicating this idea but what
is relevant to the person listening and
so to a cave person a microwave oven is
relevant because it makes food hot fast
right it makes it so that it tastes
better it makes it so that you don't get
sick you have to understand you start to
have to communicate okay why is this
important for people to understand
sometimes that is inherent right in
today's presentation I know it somewhat
is inherent that you all know that
captivating your attention when you
present is an important thing we don't
need to necessarily dwell on that
there's a reason why you clicked on the
link to join us for the happy hour today
you already are on board with that you
need to be able to Captivate people's
attention and yet we still started with
the question to say okay why is this
important what do you need to
communicate Etc right so important that
we make sure that our and communication
is relevant to the other person some
ways that we can do that is first of all
we can think about what does the
audience that we're going to be
presenting to expect
because we want to at least deliver
against our expectations or exceed those
expectations we might break those
expectations but we at least want to
understand what they're expecting and
second of all what do they need because
what they expect and what they need are
sometimes very different things when it
comes to communicating what's really
relevant to other people I really enjoy
or really follow or have gained a lot
from the process described and the red
thread a book by Hanson Webster it's a
fantastic book called find your red
thread and essentially she suggests that
most forms of effective presentations
whether it is in the format of a Ted
style talk or it's longer in a book or
it's a keynote or whatever it happens to
be there's five core components and so
tamson fantastic speaker she got her
start in uh coaching people to do tedx
talks and she I feel like has had more
people go from the tedx to tedx platform
to the full Ted platform she did tedx
Cambridge for a long time fantastic
incredibly talented and smart woman but
she presents the five kind of core ideas
to your threaded message your red thread
message is first of all you have to
understand the goal of the audience
and you have to recognize that the goal
of the audience may be very different
than your goal right so the goal of the
audience walking in what why are they
there is it because they have to be is
it because they want to get rich quick
is it because they're trying to lose
weight but you might give the example of
some people want to come in and you
might want to do a presentation on how
to eat healthy but the audience may come
in and say I don't actually care about
eating healthy I mostly just want to
lose weight right like I'm so obsessed
with the weight thing whether or not I'm
doing something healthy it's like almost
doesn't matter right you need to know
that is their goal it might not be the
goal you want for them but it's a goal
that they have coming in once you
establish that you understand their goal
then you want to talk about the problem
the reason why they haven't achieved
that goal yet and oftentimes it's a
juxtaposition like most people think X
but the reality is why for example even
with the idea of humor when we've done
research on our side the number one
cause of people not being able to use
humor in the workplace a lot of times
they say
actually I'm curious what you think go
ahead and drop in the chat what do you
think is the number one reason why
people don't use or have more humor or
levity in their work drop in the chat
what do you think the number one reason
is why people don't have more humor in
their work
but yeah the fear of not being taken
seriously that it's silly and childish
that I'm not funny not professional
they're afraid to be misunderstood they
don't know how a lot of it goes back to
this perception of other people right a
lot of people's fear comes around oh the
reason why I don't is because my boss
wouldn't approve or because I have
terrible co-workers I don't know if you
remember Bianca that's one of the
surveys that we found and the number one
thing was like the biggest the barrier
to me having more fun at work is that I
just work with awful terrible people
which might be true that might be one of
the reasons but the primary actual cause
the actual reason is because people
don't make the choice to even try they
let these potential fears prevent them
from even trying a little bit of humor
because other studies show that 97 of
CEOs prefer job candidates with a sense
of humor 81 of employees in a study of
more than 2 000 employees said that a
fun workplace would make them more
productive in fact I think something
like 60 some odd percent in that same
study he said that they would take less
money at work if they had more fun in
their job like the people are clamoring
for more humor in the workplace but we
just have this perception about work
culture to say that it isn't appropriate
now obviously there's some changes that
we need to make there but most people
let that stop them from even trying so
their goal the problem is that most
people think the issue is other people
but the reality is when it comes to
humor in the workplace it actually has
to start with yourself right and so
that's how the problem often fits when
it comes to relevant information so we
start with the goal we have to present a
problem as to why the things that people
have tried in the past aren't actually
working and then that leads into the
idea right the idea for us that humor is
a choice you choose every single day how
you do your work
and you decide whether or not you're
going to try to incorporate humor or not
right so it's that idea to the idea is
something very simple said in a single
line it's what a TED Talk might be about
and then from there you have the change
that needs to take place in order for
that idea to come into fruition and the
actions that you need to do to support
that change right so those are the five
core components of a red thread that's
for relevant information if you figure
out your five core components of a
thread in any type of presentation that
you're going to give that's going to
make it really relevant for the audience
but it's also not enough because the
problem is
that just because I as I mentioned
before just because something is
important doesn't mean it's interesting
and we all have an attention Rhythm this
is similar to a circadian rhythm right
we know that circadian rhythm everyone
has like a 23 to 25 hour clock will make
this a little bit bigger for you we also
all have an attention Rhythm or what
some of us call an attention span and by
various studies the common estimates for
how long we can have sustained attention
to a freezing freely chosen task ranges
between 5 to 20 minutes okay so let's
break that down for a minute the
estimates for a sustained attention to a
freely chosen task so what that means is
you might be really interested in the
concept but after five to 20 minutes of
things being presented in exactly the
same way you're going to naturally start
to trick out right it's just human
nature you're going to start to say okay
this is too common this is all the same
I'm interested in the topic but I need
something different and whether that's
five or 20 minutes later the audience
might be super interested in what you're
saying that it's going to be like but
also what am I going to eat a little bit
later or what meeting is coming up right
after this or what was that Ding that
just happened on my phone should I check
that email real quick should I jump into
it so what that means is that us as
presenters once we've figured out the
relevant component part that's not
enough we need to switch it up and this
brings us to the second component of
what makes for effective communication
and that is making things relatable
right so not only is it the message that
we're sharing need to be relevant to the
audience it needs to be relatable to
them as well we need to do something
different something interesting so I'm
curious go and drop in the chat what is
what's a way that you can make your
presentations a little bit more
relatable what's ways that you can add a
little bit of say levity humor surprise
something in there that's going to
capture people's attention again drop in
the chat something that you can do
you can tell a story for sure yeah you
can jump into story mode to say here's a
great example you can use some pictures
yeah you can make fun of yourself
in your direction you can ask questions
to engage them puns yeah Lisa knows
exactly what I like we can drop in some
puns into the presentation get people
paying attention as well and back that's
a good excuse anytime I see the word
puns and I think it's an excuse for a
pun let's see we're talking about
presentation this reminds me of a of a
time where a friend of mine called me
over to help me with his slides and so I
got to his house and I brought out got
my computer out got ready and all that
kind of stuff helping with the slides
because I help with presentations Etc
and he's like come on we need to go out
into the back so we're into the backyard
and I guess we're working outside here
he's like why do you have your computer
and I was like tell me what the slide is
not not no what are you talking about no
those slides he was putting together a
Playset for his kids outside he needed
help with literal slides
and I was like seriously you also said
you needed help with your deck yeah this
one the one that we're standing on so
slides and decks there's a little pun
terrible it's a terrible joke but I
appreciate the smiles and laughs from
the puns right so you can do something
and say something a little bit
unexpected right so these are all
fantastic examples of
how to make things a little bit more
relatable
and this can be
incredibly beneficial can be very
helpful I remember going to a show in at
a comedy show in uh New York City at a
place called caveat and the idea is this
astrophysicist who was on stage was
explaining
astrophysicism through Sci-Fi movies to
put it more accurately she was ruining
Sci-Fi movies because she was basically
talking about all the astrophysicist
stuff that didn't actually work she was
like there is no you can't like actually
see laser beams like you often see even
those type of sci-fi movies there's no
real big explosions in space because of
lack of oxygen and she's like the force
isn't real and I was like that is too
far space lady force is real to me at
least the force I at least I'm always
going to pretend like the force is real
anytime I go through an automatic door
does anyone else do that like you're
getting ready to walk through an
automatic door and you pretend like you
open it with your hands it's one of
life's great little Joy I appreciate
that but the reality is but she used
Sci-Fi movies as a way to capture our
attention we may not know or understand
her PhD stuff but as soon as she starts
to bring up Star Wars okay which we are
what's real what's not what are the
things that we're going to remember
Bianca did you have a question or
comment
hearing a talk about this reminded me of
if you remember one time but I did an
open mic and you had looked over my
jokes and at some point you had told me
if you feel like the crowd is you're
starting to lose the crowd you could say
uh waiting for laughter just like a
practice and there was a particular
point in the comedy set but I noticed
that everyone was looking at their
phones and not paying attention and I
dropped that line and immediately
obviously I got some laughter but
immediately the attention had spiked and
single graph that reminded me of oh my
God yes I did do that it went again and
it's I feel like it's important to have
these a couple lines in your back pocket
because that was so useful for me
because otherwise my momentum was down I
just wanted to leave it was horrible
waiting for laughter just like I
practiced so it was at the end of a joke
that got absolutely no laughter at all
right and it was just that quiet I just
said that and it was obviously a
sarcastic ironic uh self-deprecating
story joke uh and it got the immediate
laughter because it was quiet and like
oh I'm waiting for laughter but personal
laughter okay I'm over explaining good
job but no and it and it's great it's an
example of a couple of things at play
one is adding a little bit of even
something like stand-up comedy right
like one-liner comedians I I love Steven
Wright I love Mitch Hedberg I love that
style for probably 15 minutes I don't
know if I'd watched 90 minutes Steven
writes so good I maybe would but he also
even changes up his one-liners in terms
of some of them become a little bit
longer extended Etc over time anything
that becomes exactly too formulaic
across the entire thing even if it's
something like comedy sometimes get
people checking out a little bit so I
think that's a great recognition but
then also that you can have one plan
spontaneity is a great skill set to
develop as a presenter so plan
spontaneity is where you think ahead of
time okay certain situations might occur
what can I say or do if those situations
happen if I share a joke that I think
the audience is going to really laugh at
and they find it terribly boring and
don't laugh at all what's a line or a
thing that I can say oh I can say that
or you could say like this happens a lot
with crowd work and audiences plan
spontaneity is that you can say I know
when I ask a certain question like if I
ask hey crowd work of someone what do
you do
I might get certain responses right I
might get someone might say that they're
a doctor or they might say that they uh
are working marketing Etc as I start to
brainstorm the possible responses to
these questions I can start to think of
a little bit of humor or the thing that
I'm going to respond with or react with
in this situation same thing with an
exercise like the exercise that I did
before of explaining cave purse
explaining a microwave oven to a Capers
I know what a lot of the general things
are that person is going to say when I
do that so I have certain I know that if
they get to box right away okay I'm
going to make it a little bit harder and
say what is a box if they struggle for
30 60 seconds coming up with an idea and
eventually they say box okay I'm gonna
be like yes box is a wonderful idea I
know what that is right I'm going to
adjust based on the person the reaction
because I've done this enough it goes
back to that iteration that I can adjust
and because I think about it beforehand
plan spontaneity the last kind of thing
that uh Bianca also did in that moment
in that story is calling the moment or
calling the room is what we call it an
improvisation or stand up is to say
we're recognizing what's happening in
the room and that can be a great way to
break attention to Rhythm because you
can say hey I know I recognize this
thing that's happened writing in a
comedy club setting it's the idea of if
a server drops a tray full of glasses
and they all break on the ground
you have to call you have to acknowledge
that it happened you don't have to say
it doesn't have to be the funniest
punching line in the world but you like
even a symbol line like see even the
server thought that joke was hilarious
that's gonna be enough to sell the
audience hey I heard that thing happen
we can all have a quick laugh about it
and now we can move on like you don't
have to worry whether or not I noticed
it or not like I've accepted that it's
happened and I'm ready to move on past
it so the audience will as well those
are great examples of also relatability
right calling something happening in the
moment is relatability because it's
saying okay this is something that we've
all gone through this is also why
callbacks work recently in a
presentation and people were like why
are callbacks so effective and the
reason is because it's share it's a
shared moment it's like a shared inside
joke that we all have because I'm
referencing something that we've all
experienced already we feel like hey I
was I was here 10 minutes ago when we
did that thing that's cool like we're
all part of this group together right so
call box art can be a really effective
form of relatability right it closes a
little makes the people feel smart
because they're like hey I got that
so if we want to be more relatable in
terms of what we do a lot of the the
ideas that you shared in the chat are
fantastic examples stories presentations
Etc the way that I think about it is
going back to what do people know
so that we can reference to it things
like pop culture Etc and what do they
like what are the things that are going
to get them on board or interested this
was something that we did with
um the Red Cross right so this gentleman
here Pablo Suarez uh works at the Red
Cross he's seen here throwing a frisbee
at a white house uh event uh
demonstrating the nature of tornadoes so
he's already super into presenting
things in a really interesting way and
uh he and I were working together on a
presentation that he was doing on Geo
engineering and geoengineering is
basically one potential solution for
climate change where you change the
planet a little bit to try to reduce the
impacts of climate change one example or
one idea that you can do within
geoengineering is the idea of releasing
a bunch of sulfur particles up in the
air and they act as tiny little
umbrellas reducing the total amount of
sunlight that hits the Earth so he was
giving this presentation on
geoengineering to high school students
so I said when you reach that part about
sulfur particles and you said they act
like tiny little umbrellas I was like
you should reference Mary Poppins
and he was like that's stupid first of
all these are high school students I
don't know if they even care who Mary
Poppins is and second of all I don't
really like the musical Mary Poppins and
it's okay first of all ignoring the
blasphemy that is not liking Mary
Poppins I was like it's interesting I
think it'll work the beautiful thing
about Pablo is that he is a scientist so
he's like all right that's your
hypothesis Let's test it and so we
decided to set up a uh recording of uh
the students that day with their
permission we ran that video recording
through MIT emotion analytics which
tracks things like mood and attention
based on facial expressions and
recognition and create this little graph
that you see down at the bottom and
guess what happened right there where
there's that bump
yep that's right the mention of Mary
Poppins so we can see that a spoonful of
sugar helps the incredibly complex
solutions for climate change go down and
you'll notice that the attention Rhythm
and everything drops a little bit
afterwards but that's the value of
seating even just simple ideas he didn't
go into a long metaphor about Mary
Poppins he didn't explain who Mary
Poppins was Etc all he simply was like
hey it's a bunch of tiny part uh
particles up in the air they act as Tiny
umbrellas for me I imagine Mary Poppins
floating down on one of those umbrellas
that's all I said but immediately
there's a boost in intention and mood
there's smiles on people's faces Etc
even small little drop relatabilities of
this as you go through like in a simple
Association like this can be really
helpful in terms of creating more
effective presentations right and if we
do that if we know that the average
attention span is relatively between 5
to 20 minutes and it's probably even a
little bit lower in Virtual because it's
so easy to alt tab away and to email her
to something else and we know that's the
case and if we drop a little bit of
humor or levity every five minutes or so
then we're going to continue we're going
to capture and maintain people's
attention because it's always going to
be like okay what's coming up next
what's the next reference what's the
next pun what's the next exercise what's
the next prompt to the chat that I need
to do
so these are some of I think the most
effective ways to add a little bit of
relatability forms of humor essentially
so of course we're human that works a
big part of this is going to be humor is
a great way to do that so stories I
think are really helpful visuals so
interesting visuals so you can use
things like Prezi to do
picture-in-picture review if you're on
um virtual you can use images from
unsplash you could also ask AI to create
uh AI artwork for you based on a
presentation that you're giving
um incorporating a little bit of jokes
or puns levity Etc having associations
like that example of Mary Poppins and
then doing activities is another great
way to to do that so I do have another
activity that I think demonstrates this
point very quickly but I'm trying to
decide between
doing this as a breakout room or doing
this as an example demonstration
exercise so go ahead and put in the chat
would you rather do a breakout room or
see a demo with another person let's see
we'll do this as a a poll because I know
some people love breakout rooms some
people see oh we're getting demos
everyone's like the Domo if I have to go
into a yet another breakout room and
talk to strangers Etc yeah breakout
rooms make me break out I love it Mary
fantastic maybe Mary's already taken
Janine's humor writing course because
that's fantastic all right so we'll do
this as a demo in order for me to do
this as a demo though we do need one
person who is willing to come off a mute
and help me all right you need calling
out the Callback I love it so Kathy is
going to help me fantastic Kathy you can
go ahead and come off of mute
yeah
okay fantastic so what I want you to do
is you are going to tell a story and
I'll let you choose what the what you
talk about it doesn't have to be like a
full-on story but you're going to talk
about some type of topic maybe it's a
topic that you have to give
presentations on or it can be a story if
something happened to you I'll give you
a second to start to think about what
that is so you're going to tell this
story and talk about this topic and I'm
going to help to direct this story or
this topic and the way that I'm going to
do that is I'm going to go like this and
whenever I go like this means continue
on with the plot or the theme of the
topic okay but at any point while you're
talking I can switch to this motion
which means tell me more and actually
let me hide the the slide so that you
have this a little bit more video this
means tell me more and I might even
reference like hey tell me more about
blank and so then you have to just give
me more color and more detail about that
concept or that topic does that make
sense so if I was saying like so I'm
getting ready to give a prison I'm
sitting in this hotel you might say okay
oh tell me more about the hotel it's a
Sheraton Hotel in Boston and I'm sitting
across from a market where there's a
bunch of people eating food and they
have french toast which looks delicious
okay go back to the point of what you're
talking about so we're just going to
switch between these two motions so this
is continue on with the point or the
plot or the theme and this is tell me
more details about a specific thing does
that make sense yes great you got
something in mind to talk about yes all
right fantastic whenever you are ready
so not so very long ago and far away I
was going to a pottery class and I'm not
really a pottery person but I'm pretty
excited about getting the opportunity to
get out of my office and go to an art
studio and get my hands really dirty so
I'm there Art Studio oh the art studio
so it's a local it's called the center
for arts and Technologies Brockway
Center for arts and Technologies and so
they have some local artists that come
in and they have an after-school program
for students and they also have some art
classes for adults and this was really
fun because it was just one night and I
was taking this pottery class and so I
got there and I listened and it was wine
and wheel and I was having a lot of fun
and then I realized like the wheel and
the supplies so it was Clay right and so
we're all like throwing Clay on Wheels
and that was also wine so there was wine
and chips and wheels and middle-aged
ladies and it was lots of fun and so we
were learning about how to throw things
on pots and I got in and I like got
myself all centered and I was making
pots and I was having a really good time
and so I thought you were making what
did it look like
so I've haven't thrown pots for 30 years
and so some of the pots were really wide
and some of the pots were really wobbly
and some of the pots were really not
very good at all but we'll stop right
there just for the sake of time but
Round of Applause to Kathy very nicely
done oh and I wanted to keep listening
to it but just for the sake of time I
want to make sure that we we capture
that I'm curious at one it sounds like a
fantastic really fun kind of place to go
to I'm like now I want to go so maybe I
need that recommendation but I'm curious
how did it feel as a Storyteller did you
like getting direction not like getting
direction
and you're back on mute
so it was hard to follow you and make
the transitions because I was into what
I was going for and especially when you
went from
tell me more to okay move on that was
hard
yeah writing is a little bit challenging
because you have yeah as you start to
think of a story as a concept or a topic
that you want to present on Etc you
start to frame like this is how I want
to say it or this is how I can say it I
think it's going to be interesting
Etc and then as soon as someone like
throws it off a little bit you're like
but wait no I had more to say about this
thing or yeah how do I smoothly go from
talking about middle-aged ladies into
back to this thing that we're talking
about but what's interesting is that
what I really like about stories yeah
did you have a comment about that yeah
but the really hardest part was I like
forgot like I didn't get to the most
important part of the story which is I
woke up this morning and I couldn't find
my wedding rings
oh wow uh-oh and it might be in a piece
of clay somewhere
yeah really yeah so you're like I didn't
even get to the best part which is a a
great example for it going not going a
little bit long and some part of the
disadvantage of being distracted by
someone like me but what's really
interesting about storytelling is that
yeah and I agree I hope you find it as
well I left my did you get it I left my
wedding ring in Panama so I've been it
feels very weird I live in Panama most
of the time so it's not like it's not
I'm not gonna get it back I'm gonna be
there in two weeks but it does feel
weird not to have it but the idea behind
this kind of exercise is that stories
are an incredibly effective form of
communication because they can be both
relevant
and relatable
right like the plot of a story the point
of you telling a story like me talking
about being in a boring meeting at the
start of this presentation is sort of
our our happy hour today was around the
context of setting the stage for just
because something is important doesn't
mean that it's interesting right and so
it can be relevant in terms of this is
setting the stage for something but then
the added details that we go in through
like I loved hearing about these
different places and I love the idea of
just a little line of like it was a
bunch of there's wine and pottery in
middle aged ladies like to set example
is like oh that makes me laugh makes me
smile makes me picture this thing it's
relatable detail that brings me in a
little bit more right so stories can be
both relevant and relatable this the
plot part is irrelevance this is why I'm
telling you this story and this is the
relatability that we can sprinkle in
throughout So Stories are an incredibly
effective form of that but what's
interesting about the exercises is do we
get this type of feedback day to day
from people when we're talking when
we're presenting when we're sharing
ideas feedback like that I was sharing
no it's usually not this obvious
although sometimes people are like okay
wrap it up let's get to the point of
this story but oftentimes we don't see
it this obvious yeah they're pointing at
this but things like body language
is a form of feedback right because if
you and I are talking and and I haven't
gotten to know you all that much that
well and networking event Etc I might be
like slightly like not fully engaged and
then you mentioned something about
milkshakes I'll be like what milkshakes
tell me more right it'll immediately go
into tell me more because it's something
that I find interesting right whereas if
we're talking and saying a business
context you're talking with someone and
I realized like I'm super blurry for
some reason now it's now you're watching
like an old school like I'm almost
through a film class but if I am if
we're talking and things are going well
but then I mentioned something that
you're not super into right say like in
a business context we're talking about
things and then suddenly I bring a price
then that might be a thing where you're
like oh okay no I'm I need to be I'm
closed off again so it's going to change
the feedback might change based on what
you're sharing and so as a presenter to
capture attention and to maintain
attention part of it is reacting to the
group understanding like oh I was gonna
do this activity later but I realized
that people are starting to eat a little
bit antsy or we're hitting the kind of
the the bottom part of an attention
curve maybe I need to add in an activity
right now maybe I need to tell a joke
maybe I need to do a shorter side right
it's adjusting to the moment right as
you go through so that's the value
though of intentionally having these
moments throughout especially if you
have a lot of small moments as opposed
to some people are like I'm gonna start
my presentation with a joke I'm going to
do a bunch of research on what that joke
is they tell that joke and then the
remaining 59 minutes of our presentation
is boring terrible dry that's not
effective communication that's not
effective presentations it's much more
about how do you have these small
moments throughout the presentation to
maintain that attention
so that's the value of kind of the this
story so that is kind of the main focus
of what we're talking about today the
question becomes how do you then do that
how do you get better at giving those
types of presentations how do you get
better at adding humor and it's like I
talked about at the very beginning it's
all about iteration it's all about okay
how do I make these things a little bit
better each time I present them and
think about the types of things that you
have to present or you have to do often
times anyway right so one great example
of this is introducing yourself right if
you go to a networking event that can be
a fantastic way to work on how do I
capture and Captivate people even in my
own introduction let me practice on at
this networking event let me each new
person that I go to let me try a tweak
or iterate on how I introduce myself so
maybe the first time I might introduce
myself and just say oh hey I'm Andrew
and I speak on humor in the workplace oh
that's probably not people might be like
oh that's curious okay but what if the
next time I go through and I say hey I'm
Andrew and I I teach Engineers how to be
more human that's how I used to
introduce myself when I first started
humor that worked so we focus mostly on
engineering groups and so okay that
would get people to laugh and they would
be like okay how do you do that oh I
teach them skills like communication
skills leadership skills through tumor
and improvisation oh so I'm learning
through this process
and this is a beautiful thing about at
least humor and even kind of attention
is that you get that immediate feedback
you get if there is laughter you get if
there's a smile you get if there's a
leaning in and when there is you keep
that and you say okay how do I tweak
that and improve on that and when there
isn't the absence of information I've
said this in previous events no feedback
is a form of feedback so the lack of
laughter the lack of smiling or lack of
Engagement is a form of feedback which
means okay how do I adjust how do I
tweak how do I iterate and yes I think
uh iterate is very closely to the
Iditarod which I think that would be
funny that is also probably an Alaska
race is just iteration over it so that
is the main focus that I wanted to talk
about today we have a few minutes before
we'll close things out I think I saw a
question earlier on around humor and
culture but that's pretty far up let me
see
how do you use comedy when you're
interacting with many different cultures
so ask answer that question Kathy here
in just a moment if you also have a
question around captivating people or of
a comment or a thought or concern but
you can raise your hand or drop it into
the chat we can talk about it but I'll
answer this question around the humor in
different cultures and this goes back to
the understanding the audience of
relevance room relatable and also
understanding okay what does the
audience expect and what do they know
because I can make references to things
like the Halo video game which I played
way too much in University and would
constantly play and my friends and I we
still use metaphors from that video game
to explain Life we'll have in-depth
conversations about how this is like
playing on the the map Sidewinder and
when someone's posted up in a warthog
and like none of that makes sense to you
if you've never played the video game
Halo right so I need to change my
metaphor my references to match what the
audience knows and that's one thing
around culture yeah you might be a nerd
if that's what you're doing um so part
of my work as a communicator is learning
about the audience is doing a little bit
of research to say okay what do they
understand what do they know who can I
talk with in the audience beforehand or
if I'm talking and working with a client
what questions can I ask and in the
presentation or in a conversation itself
what are people reacting to what's
making people laugh or smile
so that's one of the things that
comedians will do is they'll have Test
shows where they'll share a joke and if
people laugh at that type of joke then
they can do more of that joke I do that
with puns sometimes because when working
with International audiences some groups
love them some groups hate them like
growing at them and some groups don't
laugh at all and so the groups that
laugh at puns all make more puns for the
groups that groan at puns I'll also make
more puns but I'll have a little bit
more fun to playfulness banter back with
the audience about puns and then for the
audiences that don't laugh at the puns
at all then okay I'll switch to more
storytelling or maybe I'll use more
visuals and then that's the last thing
that I'll say is from a cultural
perspective storytelling and pictures
images visuals those tend to transcend
languages language issues cultural
issues ETC because they tend to be more
human nature based right it's less about
here's a funny play on words and more
here's a human experience uh and
recognizing also when we're talking a
lot of times in the context of
presentations we can think more broad
than humor are we anything more broad
than common we can think more about this
idea of humor uh also because I'm in the
hotel lobby I am not plugged in and I
just got a notification that my battery
is low so this meeting will either end
when I close it out officially or when I
completely drop off because my battery
has completely died but maybe that's a
good kind of way to gauge when the the
attention of the the computer is done so
maybe the attention of other people has
done as well yeah and uh Bianca showed a
great uh uh point is to get feedback
from people whether it's your
significant other or uh friends of yours
that's the point of the community so
this is a great chance to plug uh the
humor that works Community is if you
have questions sought concerns you can
drop those into the community you can
say hey I'm going to be giving a
presentation to this different culture
to this different group anything that I
should be aware of is there anyone
willing to sit with me and listen to a
story and give me some feedback Etc all
of this all skills particularly humor in
a definitely around presentation skills
they get better when you get when you
practice it when you have the
opportunity to get some iterations in a
safe space because you don't necessarily
want to be trying something brand new
for the very first time in a super high
stakes environment so that's the benefit
of having friends and co-workers Etc
that connect with that's the goal that
we're trying to create out of the
communities that's a safe space for you
to be able to practice to try some new
things on to try out a new story Etc if
you haven't already be sure to join the
human networks community so that's humor
dot me slash Community as Bianca
mentioned yes this is being recorded we
drop that into the resources section of
the community so there's a whole
resources tab so if you've missed our
previous virtual happy hours you can go
back and check those out if you want to
come back to this particular one also to
do this you can take these exercises
with you the directed story is a great
exercise to work on your own
storytelling skills get your significant
other or your kids play along with them
the practice set as just a way of
telling stories and getting a little bit
of effort in there by explaining my kind
of blank so explaining your job to a
five-year-old or to a grandparent or to
a cave person Etc all great ways to
practice this as a skill and of course
you can always reach out to me we have
coaching programs Etc if you need hey I
want some very tailored specific thing
on a specific program we do offer
coaching as well with all that being
said and the battery dying down and a
two-year-old up in the hotel room that
I'm gonna go take and we're gonna go
swimming thank you all so much for
joining me for this month we'll be back
again next month in August we're still
defining the topic on that so if you
have any suggestions or requests things
that you would love to hear us talk
about definitely reach out to us at
hello humeralatworks.com with any
suggestions or drop it into the
community itself but hopefully you all
had a little bit of fun learn something
as well and now go out and enjoy the
rest of your day
foreign